well it had been snowing here for the
last several days and then to top off
all the snow we got about a day's worth
of freezing rain so there was probably
an inch of ice on top of the snow
so yesterday I was the one who suggested
to my kids
hey let's go out and sled down the big
hill outside out back because with all
the ice we'll be able to go super fast
and it'll be fun so we went out and and
then I was the one who suggested hey
let's build a ramp out of the ice
because we'll be able to go really high
off of the ramp and it'll be awesome now
I'm told that in in most situations at
least my wife tells me that usually it's
the the children who suggest dangerous
things and then the responsible adults
being the responsible one says no let's
not do that but I find that in my case
sometimes it's sort of the opposite so
we built the ramp and anyway the end of
the story is that my back is really
hurting today badly my kids are fine but
I'm I'm I am not so I would like to say
I learned my lesson but I didn't all
right welcome to the Matt Walsh oh by
the way and remember that if you want to
get the whole show if you're watching on
Facebook you only get 15 minutes if want
to get the whole show go to iTunes and
subscribe to get the whole show there or
you can become a premium member of the
daily wire okay I want to talk to begin
with about hate crimes following up on
something we discussed yesterday with
this alleged hate crime against Empire
actor
Jesse Smollett or Smollett actually not
sure happen ounce this last name I'm
gonna say Smollett because it sounds
better now look there is as I said
yesterday there's a chance there is a
technically a chance that he really was
a victim of a hate crime as he claims we
cannot at this point conclusively prove
the negative and maybe we'll never be
able to it is notoriously difficult and
oftentimes impossible to prove a
negative to prove that something did not
happen but we can use our faculties of
reason and we can
and we can use our common sense and we
can look at the available evidence and
we can arrive at a plausible conclusion
and I think the most plausible
conclusion with this story is that it is
a hoax it is a it is fake
in fact absurdly faked faked actually so
just to review the claim briefly
Smollett says that he was walking back
from a Subway restaurant at 2:00 a.m. in
Chicago in the middle of winter and it
was sub-zero temperatures but he was
going for a nice walk back from subway
and he was suddenly attacked by two
racist assailants and he says that they
assaulted him they poured a mysterious
chemical on him that apparently was
bleach they tied a rope around his neck
and they shouted this is Magga country
along with anti black and anti-gay slurs
Smollett says that he fought fought off
his assailants and he was able to attack
able to get away from the attack and
impressively he made it home with his
Subway sandwich his tuna sandwich still
intact and he still had his the rope
that they put around his neck he still
had it he was wearing it around his neck
like a necktie eventually he called the
police although according to the police
report he was hesitant hesitant to call
them but he did call them and eventually
he went to the hospital he took a selfie
in the hospital bed which is when
everyone found out about this and the
selfie shows a small scratch under his
eye but not much else in the way of
bodily injury now there are many ways
many reasons to doubt this story number
one I think the first reason is just
that it's absurd it just it's it's a
crazy story and it would be hard to
believe no matter where it was supposed
to have happen but in Chicago Chicago is
most certainly not Magga country when
you think of Magha country I don't think
you think of downtown Chicago not only
is the Chicago but it's one of the most
liberal areas in one of the most liberal
towns in in the country so you may as
well claim that you were assaulted by
maggot heiress at like a
vegan convention in in Portland or
something it's just it's the last place
in the world that you would expect to
encounter a roving band of homicidal
Trump loving bigots prowling the streets
you just you you wouldn't expect that I
you wouldn't expect to run into them
anywhere but least of all in Chicago and
the question is what were these alleged
violent bigots doing out in sub-zero
temperatures in the middle of the night
in the first place and why did they have
a noose and a bottle of bleach ready on
hand a bottle bleach which by the way
would have frozen within minutes so they
couldn't been out for very long and if
this is supposed to be a random attack
well then how did they know that
Smollett was gay they say that he says
that's part of the reason he was
attacked well you know he's just a guy
walking down the street with a Subway
sandwich if it's a random attack how
would they know that he's gay there's no
way they could have known that or was it
supposed to be targeted and is he saying
that well they they knew him because
he's a celebrity
were they out searching the streets and
risking hypothermia in order to find an
attack a relatively obscure supporting
character from a show that they've
almost certainly never seen I could tell
you one thing if these people exist they
are certainly not the kinds of people
who are going to be watching the show
Empire I think that's there's a pretty
good certainty of that but even if we
allow for the possibility that these
attackers exist and we overlook all of
the questions about why and how they
were out in the middle of the night in
Chicago in the first place that still
leaves us with the very odd fact that
sumela Smollett went home with the rope
still around his neck which just you
know if that were to happen to you and
you were assaulted in the middle of the
night someone put a rope around your
neck as soon as you escaped the first
thing you do is take the rope off right
and then the second thing you do is call
the police right away you don't wait 45
minutes you don't go home and talk to
your friends finish your tuna sandwich
ug you call them right away so it just
doesn't make any sense and it couldn't
have been and I think he claimed that he
wore the net he wore the rope to
preserve evidence well you know you
could still preserve it if you take it
off and anyway he wasn't even sure if
you wanted to call the police right away
so if you're not even sure you want to
call the police you're not gonna be
worried about preserving evidence second
thing is the video footage doesn't
support the claim that he's talking
about police have been able to piece
together most of his jaunt to and from
Starbucks or a subway and through
security camera footage because it's a
big city and there's security cameras
everywhere they there's only a 60 second
gap that they can't see so there's no
footage of the attack and there's no
footage of the assailants either and
smollett says that conveniently they say
the attack happened in that 60-second
pant span which is possible you know it
is police say that it's possible that
the the assault as described could have
began and concluded within one minute he
could have had this fight for his life
against two psychotic racists in the
span of one minute 60 seconds it's
possible possible it's also possible
that he was assaulted by a unicorn it's
it's possible that he got into a fight
with a leprechaun it's possible that you
know a giant climb down Jack's beanstalk
and and kicked him in the face I mean
it's possible like I can't say it's
impossible 60 seconds that we can't see
I mean literally anything could have
happened right but possible and
plausible or two different things third
thing is Smollett has not been eager to
help the investigation which is
suspicious you didn't want to hand over
his phone records or his phone finally
he did hand over his phone records after
about two weeks of stonewalling them but
they were heavily redacted so redacted
as to be useless for thing is Smollett
is not acting like the victim of a
vicious beating just a couple of days
after suffering he says bruised ribs
he was onstage singing and dancing and
not showing any sign of physical
impairment whatsoever which
doesn't make any sense I mean if you've
ever bruised your ribs before now broken
ribs okay it's not as bad as a broken
rib but if you ever if you've ever
bruised your rib before you know that it
hurts to breathe or move let alone get
up and and perform a musical number it's
just a couple days later you're at the
very least you're going to be invisible
pain right and then the fifth thing is
that his neighbors don't even believe
his neighbors have come out and said
that in fact quoting one of his
neighbors agent Muhammad who lives in
the same building as the supposed victim
told the New York Post I don't believe
it not around here half the people are
gay and the other half are black so it's
just that's significant because if this
look if his neighbors came out and said
yeah this kind of stuff happens all the
time
that would be kind of strange it's the
first time we're hearing of it but if if
the neighbors were saying that then I
would say okay well okay well the the
that's the plausibility dial just picked
up a few notches then in that case but
no they're saying the opposite they're
saying this kind of stuff never happens
around here so all we can do is just use
our heads and decide if this seems like
something that actually happened even if
we can't totally disprove it as I said
it's hard to disprove anything we can't
there have been many alien abduction
stories that people have claimed over
the years and we can't really disprove
any of those alien abduction stories if
some guy says that he was getting out of
his pickup truck one night heading
heading to his house and he was abducted
by an alien we can't really just prove
it it could have happened but again we
can use our heads and look at the
evidence and decide whether or not it's
plausible
but here's the thing okay so that's that
the specifics of that case hate crime
hoaxes are pretty common and that's the
other thing we have to weigh here with
this case we know that a crime hoax has
happened we know that that's just a
thing that happens by
to trump supporting racists wielding
bleach and a rope in the middle of the
downtown Chicago in 2019 we don't know
of anything like that happening so
that's something that's completely
unknown versus the other explanation
which is a hate crime hoax well Becca
know stuff happens all the time
and I think there are many reasons why
hate crime hoax has happened but one
reason that I think we need to look at
is certainly that these things happen
because of the designation of hate
crimes themselves the the very fact of
the hate crime designation seems to
encourage this kind of thing
so hate crime hoaxes happen because the
category of hate crime exists
that's one leg we can get rid of hate
crime frauds it's just getting rid of
the category and then there are no more
no more fake hate crimes right of course
that won't stop people from making up
stories he still could have made up the
same exact story but it wouldn't be a
fake hate crime they were treating this
and still are treating this as a
potential hate crime which they
shouldn't be because that category
should not exist the problem with with
hate crimes is first of all not every
kind of hate counts for a hate crime
not all the crimes that are done out of
hatred count as a hate crime which is
absurd and arbitrary so for instance if
somebody slashes a black man's tires
because they hate him personally they
have some sort of grudge against him as
an individual and they hate him they
hate his guts personally well that's a
crime and that's a crime committed out
of hate but it wouldn't be treated as a
hate crime now if somebody were to slash
the same black man's tires let's just
say he's this guy's having a bad week
and his tires got slashed you get new
tires now they're slashed again by
somebody else and and this time they're
slashing his tires because they hate the
demographic the category he belongs to
they hate him because he is a black man
not because he's that particular black
man because but because he's a black man
now in that case that's a crime same
exact crime also committed for hate and
now all of a sudden we're gonna call
that a hate crime that's gonna get the
special little tag of hate crime but why
why though why that distinction is it
really somehow not as bad to be targeted
because because the person targeting you
hates you personally I mean would it
make you feel better as a victim to know
oh no he doesn't hate my race he just
hates everything about me personally
that's all well never mind then I mean
that's okay
that's so much better no I don't think
so
if anything wouldn't it be worse it'd
mean you wouldn't it wouldn't feel worse
wouldn't it make you feel even more
violated to know that this this crime
happened out of a special disgust and
hatred for you as a person um look there
are many crimes that are motivated by
hate but we have this completely
frivolous ranking of the kinds of love
the kinds of hate that really count and
to rank them is ridiculous in the first
place but I don't even think we rank
them correctly not only that but the
second problem with the whole hate crime
idea is that hatred
isn't even the worst kind of motivation
to have for a crime um hate crimes most
of the time aren't as bad in my mind as
other kinds of crimes like like take it
a crime of indifference so if you kill a
guy for his shoes it's probably true
that you don't hate him
in fact not only do you not hate him but
you don't feel anything for him at all
you were just totally indifference to
his existence as a person you were
willing to throw away his life for a
pair of shoes because his life meant
nothing to or someone who goes in Rob's
a liquor store and shoots the clerk in
the face and kills him kills him right
that right tonight or you know someone
who gets mugged and killed for their
wallet I mean these are crimes of
indifference
you are killing somebody because you
want their money or you want whatever
they have and you just do not care about
their life the fact that they are a
living human being does not register
with you at all now I would say that
that attitude an attitude of violent
indifference is not only worse not only
more vile less human more animalistic
but it's also far more dangerous it is
far more dangerous to have somebody who
is totally indifferent to human life as
opposed to someone who's filled with
hate I mean neither are ideal but look I
tell you this if I had to choose between
sitting next to one of them on a bus I
guess I take the hateful person over the
person who just is has no regard for
human life whatsoever because you never
know what someone like that's gonna do
there was a case in Baltimore a few
years ago a a white tourist was down in
I think it was Fed Hill which is the
part of town with all the college bars
and stuff and it was st. Patrick's Day
it's back in 2012 or 2013 and the guy
was drunk you know as people tend to be
on st. Patrick's Day in the middle of
the night and so there's video of this
guy maybe you remember the skit his guy
was walking down the street and he was
assaulted
beaten knocked down strip naked and
robbed by a group of black people I
think was for black people did this now
the culprits were eventually arrested
and they were sentenced I think they
each got like a year in prison with time
served and all that kind of stuff pretty
light sentence considering the crime but
the reason why the sentence was so light
is that it was not considered a hate
crime even though the victim was white
and the assailants were black and we
obviously know that if you reverse the
races I mean can you imagine can you
imagine a video footage of of the roof
of the races reversed
of four white people doing that to a
black guy there would be hate crime
charges there would be riots in the
street there would be laws being passed
would be the only thing we talked about
on the news for days at a time
except this happens that hardly anyone
hears about it and you know they get a
year in prison or whatever but it wasn't
a hate crime the police said because
well he said well it's just an
opportunistic crime it was a crime of
opportunity okay so they beat him
humiliated him stripped him naked and
robbed him just for the hell of it just
for fun well that's so much better
or is it why is that somehow better why
is that somehow not as bad as attacking
him for his race attacking him because
they have a total disregard for him as a
person and they're just looking for a
quick thrill so they strick up strip him
naked and beat him and take his money
and you're telling me that's less
egregious and those people are less of a
threat to society
now if anything it's more egregious at
least if they beaten them because they
hate him for his race at least that's a
reason it's a bad reason but to attack
someone for no reason it's just it's
just animalistic it's I mean it's as I
said it's it's subhuman think of serial
killers think of serial killers who kill
just for the sake of killing these are
the most dangerous kinds of criminals
and also the most vile and savage and
vicious
kinds of people because of that because
they have no reason they just do it for
the sake of it
so we need to get rid of the hate crime
designation but I will say that if we're
going to have hate crimes which we
shouldn't but if we are then then I
think hate crime hoaxes false hate crime
reports should be treated as hate crimes
themselves much in the same way that I
think a a false rape accusation that
someone who makes a false rape
accusation and is proven to have made a
false rape accusation should get the
same sentence that the rapist would have
gotten and I think the same thing for
hate crime hopes because think about
what you're doing you're engendering
you're fostering suspicion and hatred
against the entire group of people who
you made this story because you because
of the story that you made up
you know if Smollett made this up and
he's trying to paint white people as
dangerous psychotic you know violent
racist and that in itself should be
treated as a hate crime
but it won't be because again the hate
crime designation is arbitrary
politically charged ideological and and
totally absurd for that reason all right
what else okay I wanted to a lot of
people are are whining I guess I could
just leave it there a lot of people are
whining that's all now in this case a
lot of people are whining because
they're getting a smaller tax refund
this year and there's been a lot of
stories about this in the news including
a there's this headline from the New
York Times
smaller tax refunds surprise those
expecting more relief and so it's just a
kind of sob story about all these people
that thought they're gonna get a bigger
tax refund and now they're not and
they're blaming Trump saying that the
tax bill screwed them over because
they're getting a smaller refund and so
forth so this is one of my great pet
peeves and and speaking of someone who
has a lot of pet peeves I just let me
just explain
something here very very simply a
smaller refund is a good thing okay you
should want a smaller refund you should
not want a big refund a smaller refund
just means that the government took less
money from you during the year so it
owes you less at the end a big refund
means that they that you gave the
government too much money and they held
on to your money without interest and
then just gave it back to you a tax
refund is not a gift it's not a bonus
it's not a winning scratch-off ticket
it's a refund a refund they are
refunding you the government is giving
your own money back to you the goal here
should be to to only give the government
what you owe the government but and I
hate even using that word Oh what you
owe them according to the you know the
law
so that should be the goal to give the
government what you owe during the year
and not much more than that so that you
can keep the rest for yourself and save
it or invest it or do whatever you want
with it you know build a deck or do with
it whatever you want to remodel you keep
do whatever you want to do go to Disney
World I mean it's your money right to
give them more than you owe just means
that they're gonna hold on to your own
money they're gonna hold it hostage and
they're gonna pay it back without
interest okay that that's why that's not
a good thing that's not something to be
excited about when people are excited
about their tax refunds it's the most
pitiful thing our our founding fathers
are getting heartburn in the grave when
they see these these foolish Americans
celebrating their tax rate oh I got a
tax refund that's your money that was
taken from you you could have had that
months ago that should have been in your
pocket all along what are you excited
about they took that from you and you
didn't even know it um complaining about
a small tax refund it's it's it's like
it's like if you lend somebody 50 bucks
and then they give you the 50 bucks back
and then you
you're upset because you wish it was a
thousand well
wait so you wish that you had lent them
a thousand dollars why wouldn't you
rather only lend them fifty and then you
could keep the other nine fifty for
yourself it's your money after all no
you see it's better to not be owed money
unless people are paying you interest
okay isn't if you're a loan shark and
people are paying you interest on it
then I guess you're gonna make a profit
but to have to have people who owe you
money and aren't paying you interest
that's not it
that's not a good thing I mean that's
not a ideal sort of situation and this
is why the withholding system is one of
the most brilliant and most insidious
and most deceitful devices ever
conceived by the government I think the
withholding system might be the best
trick the government has ever pulled it
really is brilliant and evil the
withholding system where the government
takes your money automatically with each
paycheck and then holds on to it if they
take too much and pay it back at the end
the withholding system has made it so
that the government can take even more
than it's owed and people are grateful
for it people are grateful to have the
government take too much money in fact
they're disappointed if the government
doesn't take too much you know they only
get back 100 bucks or something at the
end of the year and they say oh no
that's right
oh no that means that the government
didn't take that much too much money
from me I got to keep my own money oh no
I got to keep my own money throughout
the year this is a tragedy we have no
concept of how much we're really paying
or how much it really affects us and how
damaged we really are by the waste in
government tax day should be a painful
miserable horrible experience for
everyone we should all hate tax day the
same way we all hate the dentist and we
all hate going to the DMV we should all
hate that tax day
but again because of this brilliant and
insidious ploy on the part of the
government people are excited for tax
day not because you know the government
isn't taking their money budget but just
because of the way that it now they get
their money back on tax day they feel
like it's a profit I was I was
self-employed for one year I still have
a self-employed income but I'm I I'm
primarily paid through my job now but I
was solely self-employed for one year
and being self-employed was utterly
eye-opening and I mean everyone should
experience it at least for a short time
it was eye-opening it was shocking it
was it was traumatizing
I still have PTSD from it now I always
hated the IRS like any good American but
never more so than when I actually had
to sit there and like pull out a
checkbook and write a check for X amount
of money and I had to watch my money
March out the door and into the coffers
of a wasteful bloated behemoth monstrous
government I'm telling you that will
make a libertarian out of anybody oh
just actually pay your taxes for one
year and you'll be a liberator you will
be a radical libertarian bordering on
anarchist by the end of it I guarantee
it but the width or withholdings it and
and so if everyone had to do that if
everyone had to write a check to the
government you're not getting any money
back they're not gonna take it out
automatically you have to sit there and
write the check it's still the exact
same amount of money so the same thing
is happening it's just you are actively
involved in the process and if everyone
had to do that they would understand
they would be able to conceptualize and
get their their minds around how much
money they're paying it would become
palpable and tangible and accountability
there would be real accountability
people would be really upset by
government waste and by you know 22
trillion dollar you know national debt
and by all of the
stuff people would be really upset about
it but the system now is meant to
insulate you from the pain of being
built by the government it doesn't
insulate you from the bilking the
bilking is going on there's building
either way right but in this case you
just don't feel it because they that's
how they've structured it and that's bad
it's bad to not feel it for the same
reason that you know it's a it would be
bad to take a bunch of oxycotin and then
press your face against a hot stove now
yeah the the oxycotin the drugs will
insulate you from the pain but they're
not going to insulate you from the
damage being done to your face and so
the withholding system insulates us from
the pain of paying all this money but it
doesn't insulate us from the actual
damages the actual effect of having all
this money taken from us you know the
system now it reminds me of I don't know
if you've ever if you've ever been on a
cruise before and I don't know if I
would even recommend the way I went on
one cruise once for it was on our
honeymoon we went on a cruise and and I
I don't I assumed this is how most
cruises work but at this cruise today
they give you this little card at the
beginning of the cruise and this is what
you used to get drinks so you're not
using your own credit card you don't pay
with cash you just they just give you
this nice little you know it's a nice
little cute little card and it's really
easy like you go and you get your your
drink and you give them the card it
takes two seconds and you're not paying
any money right away but then at the end
of the week they give you your bill for
for all that all that drinking you've
been doing and then it's okay now I owe
17 they could just as easily have you
use a credit card debit card PIN pad but
they give you their own little card
because they just want to kind of
separate you from the realization of
what you're doing they want to make
the process of buying drinks as easy and
painless as possible so that you'll buy
more and you won't notice it similar
thing with the government although in
this case again there's really you know
at the end of the cruise you do have to
write the check and but with the
government for a lot of people they
never write the check
but imagine imagine a system imagine
something like if you went on a cruise
and they give you a card but it's more
of like a debit card so that the money
does come automatically out of your
account but you don't feel it you don't
realize it's happening and imagine this
imagine if if a cruise I don't wanna
give anyone any ideas but imagine if
they gave you a little debit card thing
and but for every drink they charge you
5% more than it really costs and they
take that out of your account and then
at the end of the cruise they give you a
refund they pay you back the extra that
they took well then you would feel like
you're getting paid to drink then you'd
bike twice as many drinks because you
get that nice check at the end even
though it's your own money that they
just took from you so it's that's
basically how it works so please stop
complaining about your small refunds and
be grateful that just means the
government didn't take that from you in
the first place
all right let's answer a few emails here
you could email the show Matt Walsh show
at gmail.com Matt well show at gmail.com
so this is from Colin he says hey Matt
I've come up with a drinking game for
your show one shot for having to defend
a tweet from yesterday one shot for
having to explain a position you stated
on your podcast from yesterday ok so
you've already had to take a shot for
this episode one shot for defending
having a beard one shot for reading hate
mail from your inbox one shot for making
fun of ben shapiro now i don't really do
that a lot do i I don't think I but I I
mean except for the time when Ben said
that sharp strawberry daiquiris are
better than whiskey and I threatened to
resign because of it but but I think in
that case he he certainly deserved the
criticism one shot for a sarcastic
comment ok
well then you'll just be you'll be dead
within 90 seconds if if you're doing
that one shot for quoting your own
employer the daily wire and one
additional shot if the article is
written by Amanda press to Giacomo yes I
do
steal a lot of her content for this show
that's true you're doing great work but
I'm I'm not but I'm not since starting
to participate in this drinking game
I like that Colin that's a great in fact
if anyone else has suggestions for a
Matt Walsh stroke drinking game you can
make them but yeah I would say that's
it's it's pretty dangerous because I do
a lot of this multiple times every
single day so you know but I'll tell you
this maybe one day we can all do a Matt
Walsh show drinking game together and
I'll participate I don't know if I'll
get the approval for that from the
higher-ups but I can ask anyway this is
from Chris hi Matt loved the show
yesterday when you were commenting on
the case for Christ the book case for
Christ that you would hope to have the
other side point of view I was curious
if you've seen Bill Maher's Religulous
movie and think this may be the other
side's point of view prior to fighting
my way to Christ I believed a lot of
what was in that movie I am curious if
you could speak on this in depth thanks
for all you do god bless you and your
family hi Chris I have seen it I found
it to be extraordinarily worthless and
pointless it definitely was not any sort
of serious thoughtful counterpoint to
biblical claims I wasn't really
expecting it to be because it's Bill
Maher after all it is nothing but one
long snide sneer and religious people
that's all it is it doesn't it does not
I'm not just saying that because I
disagree it just does not advance any
serious arguments at all it doesn't take
because it doesn't take religion
seriously at all and so the whole if
you've never seen the movie the whole
movie consists of of Bill Maher just
going around the country laughing and
religious people that's it around the
world actually not just the country now
so it's it's I have I have I realize
it's kind of incredible I've never
someone pluck so many low-hanging fruits
one after another after another because
he interviews
two maybe three intelligent and
knowledgeable and kind of scholarly
Christians and then only very briefly
and for the rest of the time he goes out
and he purposefully finds Christians who
clearly haven't thought too deeply about
these kinds of things yeah that's stupid
they just he finds Christians who just
they're not experts and they haven't
thought much about this the very first
scene in the movie if I remember
correctly is him at a truck stop chapel
in a chapel that's um that's a you know
literally in the back of a truck and
that's his first stop right he's trying
to find out about religion talk to
religious people and that's the first
place he goes just to a truck stop okay
this is clearly somebody who's not
interested in having a serious
conversation that he interviews a Jesus
impersonator at some kind of biblical
theme park he interviews a guy who runs
a pawn shop or something and this guy
claims that he made it rain once by
sticking a cup out of window okay so
this is the level of argumentation that
Bill Maher is interested in in engaging
with and it's just designed to generate
cheap laughter at the expense of normal
decent people who maybe don't have the
best religious education so I honestly
hated the movie okay last email again
you can email the show Matt wall show at
gmail.com this is from Josh says hi Matt
I have a two-part question one do you
think that the sexual exploitation in
the Christian Church is caused primarily
by either leaders with good intentions
who succumb to sin or wolves who enter
the church because they recognize a way
to easily gain trust from vulnerable
congregants to in either scenario the
result is a person in power who exploits
the trust of church members this got me
thinking about my own church up until
now I've had nothing but absolute trust
in our church leadership and elders but
in light of the recent scandals I can't
help but feel that
no one can be trusted I have no reason
to believe that anyone in my church
would ever do a thing like this but I'm
sure that's exactly what every other
victim thought must we as churchgoers be
ever-present with our children never
letting them alone with any church
leader or member for that matter love
the show Josh hi Josh Josh I I
definitely don't think that the first
option is the case the people who commit
or help to cover up or ignore sex abuse
definitely do not have good intentions
that doesn't mean that every bishop or
church elder or whoever who looks the
other way on sex abuse it necessarily
actively wants there to be sex abuse for
most of them it's simply cowardice and
self-interest but I wouldn't call
self-interest a good thing and that also
doesn't mean that every single sex
predator in the church necessarily
joining the church in order to have
access to victims although I think
that's probably the case for a lot of
them and it you know it also depends on
there are different levels of abuse
different kinds of abuse you know so
it's it's sort of to try to talk about
what leads to this and motivations to
talk about in such a general way is a
little bit difficult to do but by the
way these are these are evil evil
scumbags as to your second question that
is tough because of course we have to
keep in mind that sex abusers are still
a very small minority in the church very
small yet it is a problem that exists
and we have to account for it we can't
ignore it
we can't be untrusting and suspicious
and paranoid all the time but we should
be cautious so there is definitely a
fine line between caution and paranoia
and that is that I admit as a parent
that's a sometimes a very difficult line
for me to draw here's what I would
suggest we should treat church leaders
or pastors or priests like we would
anyone else
we shouldn't implicitly trust them with
our kids completely and automatically
any more than you would trust a stranger
because if somebody is a member of a
church leader of a church and you don't
know them well then there's still a
stranger but as you get to know someone
better then you're you're more equipped
to make judgment calls about them of
course those judgment calls can be wrong
can be tragically wrong but that's the
best we can do really we could only make
judgment calls about people and then and
then go from there
the only other option is to keep our
kids locked in their rooms until they
turn 18 which obviously we can't do I
think the main point is that we can't
trust a person just based on the office
or position they hold if there's any
practical lesson that we can take from
all of these sex abuse problems and all
these different institutions that's it
that you just because someone holds a
certain position or they have a certain
title or a certain office or or whatever
else that does not mean they can be
trusted which isn't to say we can't
trust any of them
but we can only trust people really
through getting to know them on a
personal level that's how we can trust
them we cannot assume that oh he's a
fill-in-the-blank position and therefore
I can trust them or Iza you know he does
this and so therefore he would never do
that it would be nice if we could say
that about pastors and priests and
church leaders and church members but we
can't and that's the mistake I think a
lot of people have made I think back in
the Catholic Church back when the the
the abuse situation was really really
bad back before it had been exposed back
in the 70s and 80s many parents would
leave their kids alone with priests who
they did not know but they didn't think
anything of it because it just didn't
occur to them that a priest a priest of
all people would do something like that
now after these kinds of things come out
and it's big news and everything well
then it's easy to have more caution but
before that happens I think people just
it just they don't even
to them this is true of other positions
as well it's true of any position think
of doctors there's a big sex abuse
problem in the medical field which
doesn't which it doesn't isn't talked
about very often and we are conditioned
to trust authors and many doctors are
worthy of trust but no doctor is worthy
of implicit trust just simply because he
is a doctor there's nothing about
becoming a doctor that necessarily
requires you to be a trustworthy person
there's nothing about any position um
there's nothing about the position of
pastor or priest that inherently weeds
out untrustworthy people same for police
officers same for teachers everybody so
think of for instance the the worst
pedophile you know you know the worst
pedophile in American history the worst
pedophile in American history is a guy
named Earl Bradley and he was a
pediatrician in Delaware he molested
hundreds and hundreds of his patients he
was he was like the the pedophile
version of karma Gosnell basically and
in fact his story this story came out
around around the same time as Gosnell
within a few years I think um he
molested hundreds of his patients small
children he got away with it because
parents would leave him alone with their
kids parents would send their you know
four or five-year-old kids back with
this pediatrician and and then these
terrible things would happen and I'm
sure those parents it just never
occurred to them it never occurred to
them that a pediatrician would be a
child molester because he's a doctor
after all and of course it's very easy
for us now to say well how could you do
that I mean as a parent it's so reckless
but look I remember I live not far away
when this happened and I was much
younger I didn't have kids at the time
myself so I'd never had to really think
about this issue very much but yeah I
remember when that happened I was
talking my mom about it and she said oh
yeah you'd never send your kid back with
a doctor and you never leave a kid alone
with the doctor and I remember what she
said is it really I didn't is that I
guess I hadn't thought I'd have kids I
didn't really think about it but but
yet it hadn't occurred to me at the time
and I think that's just how it is with a
lot of people people say well he's a
doctor of course you can trust him and
the same kind of mistakes are made in
regards to teachers and you know Scout
leaders and any other similar kind of
position so again the point is that well
the point is not that we have to suspect
everybody and we have to think that
everyone's a child molester the point is
simply that we can't put our absolute
trust and faith in someone just because
of the position or office they hold and
sad to say this is also true in families
most abuse happens within families that
is the tragic and disgusting fact now
hopefully you trust your family but you
trust them because you know them
that's why hopefully you can trust your
family uniquely because they're in a
unique position to really get to know
them because they're your family
but you don't trust them just because
they're family so you don't trust say
your uncle or an uncle with your kids
just because he's an uncle that doesn't
mean anything
probably most child molesters in the
world are our uncles of someone right so
just because you're an uncle doesn't
mean anything but you trust an uncle
with your kids if you know him and you
have the opportunity to know him well
because he's a close family member I
think there are many many cases of abuse
by family members or the other people
the family I think maybe maybe probably
do get kind of a weird vibe from this
person they hear stories they catch a
whiff of something and but they say no
no no he's they're ugly would do that
in fact there are many cases you talk to
people who were abused when they were
younger and you hear their stories and
they'll tell you that sometimes they
even told their parents or they told
people or they at least hinted at it
very strongly and everyone said now he
was he's a family would never do that
so that logic just doesn't work you know
all of my my brother my brothers-in-law
I trust them absolutely with with the
kids but not because their uncle's only
because I know them very well and I know
that they're they're very good decent
virtuous trustworthy people so that's
the reason that that sort of position or
office if we want to call it of family
member in and of itself means nothing
unfortunately all right so we will leave
it on that somewhat depressing note have
a great day everyone talk to you
tomorrow
Godspeed